right okay now we turn to the nation's
covet crisis and the growing number of
children that are getting sick last week
more than 200 000 new pediatric cases
were reported across the country that's
a more than five-fold increase over the
past month this comes amid the ongoing
fight over school mass mandates
including in florida a state hit
especially hard by the spike in coveted
cases manuel bajorkas is there manny
good morning
good morning currently on average 61
children a day are being admitted to
florida hospitals with covett 19
according to the cdc for perspective
before this surge that number was just
six per day yesterday a judge affirmed
his ruling that the state and the
governor do not have the authority to
ban mass mandates in schools governor
ron desantis is now appealing
for us this is not about politics
this is truly about a pandemic florida's
governor banned mass mandates in school
but the state's second largest school
district broward county is pushing back
requiring masks in class unless a child
has a medical exemption so the state is
following through on its threat to
withhold funds equal to school board
members salaries ignoring a judge's
ruling that struck down the governor's
ban
ultimately
when it comes down to
students well-being i trust the parents
more than i trust the government but
doctors say trust the science especially
in light of the numbers children have
made up about 15 percent of documented
covit cases in the u.s but as of the end
of august the percentage has risen to
above 22 percent they're getting
infected from people who are
unvaccinated and so it's not your right
as an american to catch and transmit a
potentially fatal infection any more
than it's your right to run through a
stop sign at an intersection dr paul
offit with children's hospital of
philadelphia says the approval process
takes time so a vaccine for kids under
12 may not be available until at least
the end of the year
well you know you want to make sure that
you you have done the studies in the
right way that most importantly show
that this vaccine is safe safe safe
because you're about to put
it into millions of children catherine
perilous two-month-old son junior is
much too young for the vaccine or the
battle he's fighting he's been in
intensive care in new orleans for three
weeks due to covit he already had you
know respiratory issues
so
when the virus when he caught the virus
it just doubled up and made things
entirely worse
she has this message i want everybody to
realize is that you know we have a virus
out that way
out here that is impacting now it's
impacting our children
and they are our future and whatever we
can do as a community
to make sure that we protect our future
then we need to offer that to our
parents
out there
even when a vaccine for children 12 and
under is finally approved the next
challenge will be vaccine hesitancy of
those 12 to 17 who are currently
eligible less than half are vaccinated
tony oh manny we're rooting for that
family thank you very much
and this